we can done it fully here speaking of
your brother we're gonna drink these and
cheese brothers get he weight shop I
need to tell you something what I want
to [ __ ] your brother this weekend are
you out of your mind
what no he's been posting some
thirsty-ass Instagram photos and like
haven't seen him in a few years he
looked [ __ ] good look he looks like
he's been in one of those lens makers he
was it a lens makers commercial what
lens makers gives you the freedom
freedom to stand out
[Music]
freedom to be bold
[Music]
the freedom
to be me what do you see you can't [ __ ]
James dude why not because Kelsey I had
very very distinct plans in my head to
lay with Larry this weekend
I've we've been talking ever since
Daniel Radcliffe favored it throughout
history do not say you're going to lay
with my brother when I was second of all
you can do
Larry I don't care he probably needs to
get laid I support that we can't do it
at the same time you can be [ __ ] my
brother while I'm [ __ ] yours there's
no rule about Rob or you ain't being all
right hold on
hello yeah we're across from the third
United sign from the left if you're
looking at the airport oh my god you're
so stupid
okay you'll have to tell me about it
later okay we'll see you soon okay bye
that your brother yeah we talked on the
phone
hey my [ __ ] readout oh yeah okay
all right here we go left hands you're
gonna lose that'll wake is a John way
it's great we've always been I don't
like on the same pages as crazy it
sounds like she's never even seen John I
didn't even have to draw John go and get
my point
let's go start the time and go okay here
we go or don't okay thanks straight it's
so hot here it's my boobs are sweating
that's time by the way
cool thanks guys it was a reason the Sun
Raisin in the Sun oh come on do you see
that tilt your head and jocks we're
gonna do shots we're gonna take shots
and I will go get the tequila your
favorite I know Kate so bring it on you
know what at this point you learn a
little a while just gonna bring unified
right through here I'm good in a way a
little Tanner parent phone charger
[Music]
identity Kela is 80 years old I had to
dig it out of the ground on my mission
trip to Mexico last year mission trip to
Cabo food you out there again I don't
know you're not gonna puke just because
you have one little measly shot it's
great you puke thing few pukes want to
ever hit drinks tequila really vacations
maybe don't ruin it frisky as well [ __ ]
you you're acting like creepy weirdest
neighbor repeat didn't wear a shirt all
the way buttoned up so we'll just
unbutton it like a smooth criminal I
could move my whole mouth on this watch
oh stop it waltz of it James do your
computer guy right no I have an iPad I
want you to look at but it's a mere room
so you have to come to my room right now
the iPads are highly portable it's a
special one Kelsey I work at the Apple
storage Larry
Jesus um hey you want a chip only if you
feed it to me
okay don't forget the tip
I turn for the real picture you know
what I can't find it
I don't know what to do with it no
worries just stuff let me know if you do
and I'll come back and knock yeah
actually I had one more question for you
okay I'm just started working out you
sneezes Friday yeah that's funny you are
like this grunion no do I know what else
yeah clean living mmm start working out
home watching YouTube videos you know I
started eating healthy I'm here or is it
just you just kidding you know what it's
a little toasty mmm Advent looks a
little gnarly who's lost some air that
thing dusted it's been a while since
anyone dusted my vents do you mind
looking at it I mean I know you love to
fix things
let's do it you have a screwdriver I got
a screw something comes too many chips
so many you're right I really wasn't
even that hungry to begin with you don't
mind I might come but in my pants oh
yeah this is like the dustiest men I've
ever seen that should yeah it's coming
through or so but that's the beginning
cool ah what dating situation like back
home by the way datings well speak of
that six months ago Tracy and I we see
me oh we should [ __ ] hired me right on
the spot
I became an apple genius wow that's
crazy
oh yeah well something
are you alright you know I have that
thing that you start don't do it I don't
know this is kind of crazy I mean you're
like a sister to me look at this we have
known each other for forever so we can
skip the awkward pleasantries plus I've
pretty senior Derek remember in third
grade in the back of the bus when that
real dared you do and you're like what
and I was like what's that
[ __ ] that kid listen I'm just not ready
[ __ ] it what's that noise it's probably
for the best right until Christmas when
I'm gonna [ __ ] your brother I'm out of
luck damn so good yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
your brother first I'm gonna become part
of your family